Hi Internet
We heard you were angry at Joanna.
Wait, what?
Your video toolbar does not cover all roaming methods in the app
What about that?
I will tell you. wait. I only had two minutes,
The Internet is very slow.
Wait, wait. Do not leave. There is nothing wrong. It's important. We will go beyond it.
We just have to talk about browsing the appBar appBar and Toolbars
Okay. If we scroll on the scrollFlags .
It's not just scrollFlags .
We have to talk about the whole subject.
Funny fact.
In fact, AppBar is just an ActionBar with a fancy name.
Well, it's not just a new fancy name.
It is the basis for your entire application.
If true
Do not think they should call him AnchorBar
The AnchorBar looks ridiculous
The Android system has nothing ridiculous.
of course not.
But in any case, you can customize AppBar
If you choose to use a toolbar instead of choosing a traditional frame structure.
- Thanks, Ian. - you are welcome.
- As I explained in DevByte - this really is good. You have to watch it.
Thanks Ian.
But it really does not answer the question of where the scroll feature lies?
Well, but it's an AppBar model of course.
But you are right. I still have not talked about the usefulness of scrolling.
You are probably right that you have to talk about him
It is important.
Okay.
So I was--
If you want the tools to pass with a click
To help you put content in a great way
By hiding Chrome from your app? Yup. Okay.
If you decide to use AppBar,
You'll need three things.
The first thing is a coordinated outward appearance above.
- Thanks Ian. - Not to thank on duty.
You will then need the AppBar layout that contains the toolbar.
Then you will finally need
To original content such as RecycleView .
- Thanks Ian. - Not to thank on duty.
Now if you forgot to specify the external appearance style
Your application will deteriorate and will not prove.
So do not forget him.
Finally scrollFlags attribute
Is the magic that will allow the application to work.
- Deterioration? Is this really a word? - Yup
- I do not see it - I learn? If it was not a word I would not use it.
I believe her.
So what do these scrollFlags do for your application?
Well, the scrolling process
I assure you that everything will pass on the screen.
And enterAlways assures that it will rotate as soon as you re-scroll.
Wonderful
Quick style.
It is indeed a common pattern.
Specifically.
So we hope this has helped you--
In understanding the process, developers.
- Thanks Ian. - no problem.
So go make better apps
Stop. Stop.
Done well
I created the best apps!